American businesses and consumers will
pay more for many Chinese imports after
the u.s. increased tariffs on 200
billion dollars worth of goods and that
happened overnight there is now a 25%
tariff on Chinese products worth a total
of 250 billion dollars
Trump administration raised the tariffs
in the middle of trade talks that
continue today in Washington we just
sang is at the White House we a good
morning good morning John President
Trump says the two biggest economies in
the world were getting very close to
reaching a deal but then Beijing back
pedaled on concessions and tried to
change the language in the proposal just
a couple minutes ago he tweeted that the
talks with China continue in a congenial
manner and there is absolutely no need
to rush he also insists tariffs will
bring in more money than any traditional
agreement well he just wrote me a
beautiful letter I just received it and
I'll probably speak to him by phone
President Trump had nice things to say
about his Chinese counterpart Xi Jinping
but his actions spoke much louder at
midnight tariffs on 200 billion dollars
of Chinese goods more than doubled from
10 to 25 percent taken well over a
hundred billion dollars a year we never
took in 10 cents from China not 10 cents
just hours before the new taxes kicked
in a Chinese delegation met with US
Trade Representative Robert light Heiser
at his office along with Treasury
Secretary Stephen minuchin I'm for the
USA I'm for the USA all week mr. Trump
dialed up the threats that he's walked
back before at a rally in Florida by the
way you see the tariffs were due because
they broke the deal
they broke the deal and on Twitter where
he complained the negotiations for a
trade deal were moving too slowly the
president blames China for stealing
technology and pressuring American
companies to turn over trade secrets
allegations Beijing denies if the two
sides do not reach a trade agreement mr.
Trump says he's prepared to put 25%
tariffs on another 325 billion dollars
in Chinese imports which would cover
everything the country ships to the US
he says that may be a blessing for
American manufacturers it'll be the old
fashioned way the way we used to do we
made our own product but in February the
trade partnership and economic
consulting firm estimated these new
tariffs plus the ones already in place
will cost the average family of four
seven hundred and sixty-seven dollars a
year still the president is confident
his strategy has boosted the economy and
is well received by his supporters John
we sure thank you